hoy podemos volver a respirar así de
contundente fue la reacción de uno de
los hermanos de georges floyd tras
conocer el veredicto de culpabilidad
para derecho bin el ex policía que
asesinó a su hermano en mayo del año
pasado
estoy luchando por todos en este mundo
si recibo llamadas recibo mensajes gente
de brazil de ghana de alemania de todo
el mundo de londres de italia todos nos
dicen lo mismo no podremos respirar
hasta que tú puedas respirar hoy podemos
volver a respirar ct uidd que las
reacciones a la sentencia llegaron
también desde las más altas esferas de
la política estadounidense empezando por
el presidente yo wyden quien hizo un
llamado a que este caso suponga el
primer paso para un cambio en el país no
puedo respirar no puedo respirar
esas fueron las últimas palabras de
george floyd no podemos dejar morir esas
palabras con él debemos seguir
escuchando esas palabras no podemos y no
debemos apartarnos de esto
tenemos la oportunidad de empezar un
cambio en este país el cambio en el
sistema policial y judicial
estadounidense ha sido durante mucho
tiempo un clamor en las calles
abanderado por el movimiento black light
matter ahora lo es también en la arena
política desde la bancada demócrata en
la cámara de representantes fueron
varios los legisladores que quisieron
sumarse al llamado del presidente en
actuar pero seguiremos estando
resilientes como parte del esfuerzo para
aprobar una legislación de reforma
policial significativa y para
literalmente levantar el principio de
libertad y justicia para todos en eeuu
ahora habrá que esperar hasta un máximo
de ocho semanas para conocer las penas
de prisión que deberá cumplir jobing en
cualquier caso no superarían los 29 años
dado que no cuenta con antecedentes
penales